let's get it started with crystal in las
vegas nevada
crystal how can we help hi
thanks for having me on well one of
the issues i have is that i've been at a
company for like
two years and i'm not really getting
promoted in my career
and i want to move to another city to
get a better job but my boyfriend
doesn't want to move
and we want to get married now if i stay
in las vegas i can't work anywhere
else because as a journalist we have
these things called non-compete
so it's either i stay here and get out
of journalism
or i move and kind of break up with him
yeah well let's talk about you for a
second well let's forget about him
i'm not real thrilled with him but we'll
get to him in a moment john i might have
doc
weigh in on this from a relationship
standpoint that's his area
but i do want to get really clear on
what your dream is in this other city
and why you want to go there i want you
just tell yourself not just us
why do you want to move forget him why
do you want to move why is that
important
because i work a really tough schedule i
work
like midnight to 8 am wednesday through
sunday and i fall asleep in church and i
don't really have much of an outside
life out of work
so i want to find something with a
better schedule
and that i can kind of move up the
ladder with go
why why'd you get into journalism
because i feel like everyone needs to
have their story told
and i wanted to be a representative for
people of color in different communities
and to make sure that
everyone's accountable why go one level
deeper i love that answer tell me why
that's important to you
because when i was growing up in new
orleans and hurricane katrina happened i
felt as a person of color i was
personally ignored
and no one was paying attention to me
and that inspired me to perceive this
career in journalism in which i tell the
story of people
who are at the bottom and who are being
ignored in society
john that's a why hey that's a why
that one's wired into your soul that's
from your story
so here's the deal the reason i just
walk you through that
is because you need to have that front
and center right now john's gonna walk
you through the relational piece
uh but i wanted you to hear you share
why it's so important that this this
isn't a move just for a j.o.b
this isn't a move to make your boyfriend
uncomfortable
this isn't about you and selfishness
this is about your purpose this is about
your why
you need to make the move john i think
she makes the move whether he comes or
not and if they're talking marriage
and he's not willing to make a move
because of that
why i got some real problems john help
me out i'm the same so crystal walk us
through
i'm going to call him a knucklehead and
that's that's a that's that's my neutral
right that's pretty gentle it's right
down the road in the middle of the road
for me
tell me about this knucklehead what what
what a what a part about
your life mission is he not resonating
with
well i mean he's been here for a long
time like this is his
um home city so i definitely understand
it
everything that he knows and loves is
here
part of me doesn't want to move either i
actually like the city it's just that
i'm not really progressing here at the
current company that i'm at
how long has your non-compete for
for a year a year have you
sat down and dreamt about and i'm i'm
wandering back in the kin's world here
have you
dreamt about other ways to tell stories
of marginalized people
that that would allow you to get some
experience and some skills and then
in 366 days you slide back into this
role
yeah i thought about starting a small
small community newspaper for um
and a kind of lower income area of the
city here
crystal how much money do you need to
make
not really that much it's not really
about the money
well i understand i understand sanity
sure you got to pay bills though yeah we
got some realities how much money do you
need to make you're not married remember
the
so this is a boyfriend he didn't put a
ring on it yet how much money do you
need to make
probably fifty thousand dollars okay i
just want to be real honest with you
uh john's asking you the right question
there might be some other ways
to get to where you want to get to
besides moving from vegas to this job
however they've got to be realistic and
you're starting a community newspaper
you're not going to make 50 000. you're
gonna lose 50 000. yeah that is a that
is not
a reality and i don't want to let you
think that that's a reality
i want you to go back to the question
john yeah you didn't answer the question
you just talked about how
you understood his point of view because
he's always lived in vegas and
everything he loves
is in vegas well it's about ready to not
be the case and
if he loves you uh i want to know john
asked you a really good question what
part of that vision that you so
beautifully shared with us
does he not get excited about
he just doesn't see the need for me
to move he kind of believes that i
should be able to start my own
thing here whether it be like a website
tv station newspaper etc i don't think
he really has a grasp
of uh yeah a reality
of journalism yeah you know he needs a
grasp of two things number one
uh how media like that actually operates
how long it takes to get up and running
how much money it spends off and oh by
the way you have to take care of
yourself you're not relying on boyfriend
i think this is a sit-down conversation
john where it's like this is my vision
now to john's point
i don't think you have to put all the
eggs in this basket of moving out of las
vegas however
this move to this new position
moves you up the ladder that was the
word i got most excited about
ladders what's great about ladders is as
we move up
we have other options to move to
different places you could come back to
vegas but the reality is crystal you are
capped you have a lid on yourself
your words your reality it's a lid where
you are now and if you
don't leave soon to do what
you know you're supposed to do whether
it's this position john where she moves
out of vegas
my concern is she's going to begin to
resent the boyfriend and i see that over
and over and over where people a they
don't have the
the why conversation they don't get to
why it becomes a j.o.b i want this title
and that's not a reason to move it never
but when you're that wired into who you
are
and your mission on earth then that's a
sit-down conversation
because five years from now 10 years
from now that's when the
the fires of resentment will burn
through that relationship and it's hard
to maintain when you have a mission in
life i'm gonna tell you this right now i
wouldn't marry anybody who wasn't on
board with what i believe god created me
to do
sorry